si en bourgogne à deux choses qui sont
sacrées la première c'est de faire le
meilleur vin possible tournant à la
terre et la deuxième c'est la
transmission voix ce maréchal veulent
états financiers de l'entreprise vous
allez être placée sous tutelle
judiciaire
on n'a pas le droit de faire n'importe
quoi tv numeric plaît beaucoup plus une
papaye est juste là pour faire du vin
pour moi ça n'avait de sens que quand on
était une famille fait des nouvelles de
charlie je m'inquiète pour les enfants
c'est aussi un peu à leuze de mails
dragon m'a rien dit sur le sujet quoique
avignon pendant jeu trop mûres 8 sur
leur image votre truc 150 mètres carrés
en plein coeur du marais voitures de
luxe et l'assistante enchaînait sur les
soeurs on va tout vendre
on fait tourner 12 depuis 15 ans et
maintenant que ça dérape samoa de
réparer tana pour un an maxime charland
je m'étais tu le connais pas tu l'a même
jamais appris tu va m'aider lavigne j'ai
pu lui papa sow j arriverai pas
on va vinifier comme à l'époque d'avant
la technique d'avant la chimie et tu vas
les effets d'un côté va mal quand les
enfants comme les romains entré chez toi
charlie ici tu perds ton temps tu me
fait perdre le bien de façon maintenant
c'est quitte ou double
si on ne change rien on refera les mêmes
conneries
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il faut tout
remettre à plat ça tombe bien parce que
c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est non pas
plus dans les grottes avec les mains
depuis quand on a inventé le pinceau ça
s'appelle l'évolution
ses sympathies rien à faire à part a été
la plus personne n'a jamais fait ça
charlie ben nous on va faire
mais le choix se fait pas de bruit pas
au bout de ses millésimes
après tu fera le bilan ces médiévales
ton truc toujours ré ce qu'il disait
gandhi au début et ignorent après ils se
moquent à la fin et imite et j'ai dû
bien grandi ça va marcher je te dis
j'espère parce que sinon on reste soudé
nos gueules jusqu'à la fin de nos jours
je crois qu'ils vont être bons nouvelle
chérie tu pourras g par jour dégoûté